طب ايش رايك في شباب اليوم يا ستي اياهم
الله يكلهم معين عليها الله يسع يسعدهم
على اياهم اللي موظف ها الحمد لله زي الهم
اللي بده يتعلم ويتوصف ربنا يوفقه اللي
بده يتجوز ربنا
يعينه اعرفك عني اناي مهاجره من نعليه ومن
عيله دار
الكحلوت هزرنا من نعليا من الحرب من
اليهود ايش صار معكم بالشيخ رضو قبل ما
تيجي هنا عب دارنا واقفين نحن واولادنا
صار التفجير في جنب في دارنا جنب الدار
اللي نحن فيها يعني هواء في دارنا ما
قدرنا نضلنا قاعدين صار التفجير وين مكان
صار الخبط وين ماك كان قلنا خلص مالنا الا
طلوع قوا طلعوا من وجه الضرب اللي تص لكم
الحجات طلعنا طلعنا على في الاول اول رحله
على خاني يونس وبعدين ضح جينا هان طلعونا
من هناك قال روح لكم غد ايم لكم وه طل
الليله الخبط داير اخذتي من بيتك لما طلعت
ولا حاجه والله ما طلعت لين غير الي والله
ما طلع لوين غير الي غير اللي علي هال
الجلابيه اللي علي وحده غيرها يا رب هذا
طلع جايب ليك انت واوا عينا بعفش بحالنا
من حمانا كله والله ظل في البلد انت
بتخافي من القصف القصف بخوف الكبير
والصغير الكل بخاف منه لانه هذا قصف اعمى
وين ماجي بخبط ولا لا ايش بحبوا يعملوا
المجادله في ايش مشهورين في النصج ش
المجدل شغلها نسيج كل القماش هم اللي
بيشتغلو كانوا من الثوب المالطي للثوب
المجدلاوي اللي كانبس مخطط هيك كانت عند
حدا ه خط وه خط بكف الثوب عرض الثوب ه
القده وبن فصله ابو 200 وجنا ونار وزلزله
وشامي الشامي مطرز اسمر والباقي هذول
الالوان هذا خط اخضر وخط احمر هذا الثوب
المزلاوي المزاد في المالط وفي البفت وفي
ملابس الزلام القمصان كله كانوا يشتغلو كل
ملابس الناس من المجدل المجاد ل كان
شاطرين شغيل شغالين راسين 100% وايش
مشهورين في الاكل طيب الاكل كل الناس
اليوم زي ما انت عارفه الناس مشهوره في
الاكل
بيعملوا معزومين عننا بنعملهم ص رز ومفلفل
منسف منسف عاملين منسف نجيب هال اللحمه
ونطبخها ون فلفلها الرز في مركت اللحمه
ونبر ه هال المركه ونضبط ونحط هال اللحمات
بتصلح له الوجوه اذا في فراخ بنطبخ ونزبط
ونحمرهم ونزبط بنعمل الرز وبنحطهم على
وجههم و بدهم فت بفت لهم تحتيه بدهم مش فت
عادي رجعنا على نعليه راح تعزمينا عندك يا
100 مرحبا يا ريت بعزمك على عجل على عجل
بعزمك وبجيبك بس تيجي اهلا وسهلا والله يا
ريت نرجع على علي والله لو بدي نرجع علىنا
علي ان كان كل يوم علي كلها في عرسه وطبل
زغريت وكل الدنيا يروحوا اولادهم في
الدنيا عزم الوطن قال والله الغربه مليحه
والله الغربه مليحه لكن الوطن غالي لكن
الوطن غالي يا عمي يا سمي يا عمي يا سمي
والله الغربه مليحه لكن الوطن فيش عزم
[موسيقى]
الوطن
l